the fight against climate change is the
greatest obligation of our generation,
but it is also the greatest opportunity
because europe is a leader in the
development of many climate-friendly
technologies,
we have the innovative companies
that can turn such research into
products and we have the
experience that it is not only in  to be able to
market our domestic market but worldwide
and your commitment today also shows
that a lot of people are already
striving in this direction and i would like
to take this opportunity to thank you
for positioning yourself loud and clear for a climate-neutral economy made
in europe
and you are  not only
do i get regular letters from cios and
investors, from small companies
to medium-sized companies to the
very largest companies in the world, and
they all have understood that this
old trend line
no longer works here, on the contrary, the
european green deal is hot  t sustainable
economy and other growth
growth that gives back more to the planet
than it takes from it you understand
change and you want the
european union to support
you to become strong and remain competitive in the market of the future